erster corona fall in deutschland in
bayern steckt sich ein mann bei seiner
chinesischen kollegin an der
gesundheitsminister verschärft die
regeln für fluglinien zu wenig material
zu viel bürokratie
der wehrbeauftragte des bundestags
zweifel die verteidigungsfähigkeit der
bundeswehr an
doch noch im halbfinale roger federer
wehrt sieben matchbälle ab und besiegten
australien den us-amerikaner
tenniscenter
[Applaus]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen
hier sind die nachrichten dieses tages
inklusive sport mit norbert lehmann 1
übernahm durch von mir das corona virus
hat deutschland erreicht und einen
jungen mann in bayern infiziert der
kontakt zu einer chinesin hatte
trotzdem besteht für mediziner kein
grund zur panik sie raten vielmehr zu
aufmerksamer gelassenheit auch für
gesundheitsminister sparen gibt es
keinen grund für übertriebene sorge die
gefahr für die gesundheit der menschen
in deutschland bleibe sehr gering
patricia schäfer in dieser münchner
klinik wird der erste deutsche corona
virus patient behandelt
der 33 jährige mann aus bayern hat sich
außerhalb chinas infiziert und zwar bei
einer chinesischen kollegin seiner firma
im landkreis starnberg
dem patienten geht es sehr gut er ist
fieberfrei hat auch derzeit keine
atemwegs symptomatik mehr
gestern habe der mann noch gearbeitet
teilten die bayerischen
gesundheitsbehörden mit er ließ sich
jedoch untersuchen weil er vor einer
woche an einer schulung mit einer
chinesischen kollegin teilgenommen hatte
bei der nach ihrer rückkehr nach china
eine infektion mit dem corona virus
festgestellt wurde
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen sagte
der fall zeige dass die melde und
behandlungskette gut funktioniert wir
sind zuversichtlich dass sich eben weil
wir entsprechende verdachtsfälle und
infektionsfälle dann auch zügig in den
blick und in die behandlung bekommen
dass wir dann eben auch gut damit
umgehen können und eine weitere
ausbreitung des virus in deutschland
verhindern können
deutschland werde die piloten von flügen
aus china verpflichten den tower vor der
landung über den gesundheitszustand der
passagiere zu informieren
reisende aus china müssen angeben wo sie
sich aufhalten und die kliniken müssen
nun auch verdachtsfälle melden virologen
beruhigen eine ansteckung mit dem corona
virus extrem unwahrscheinlich ein fall
heißt im moment einfach die zuständige
landesbehörde und auch die anderen
staatlichen behörden
haben natürlich sofort angefangen
kontaktpersonen zu screenen haben
gesucht ob es mögliche weitere
übertragungen geben könnte bisher ist da
nichts bekannt und ich halte die gefahr
für sehr gering
die münchner klinik bestätigte am abend
dass der erste deutsche corona virus
fall einen harmlosen verlauf zu nehmen
scheint beruhigend zu wissen dennoch
sind genaue und fundierte informationen
gefragt und deshalb ist es so wichtig
dass china sie auch liefert dort meldet
man inzwischen rund 4500 erkrankungen
und 106 todesfälle wie aber kann man
sich hier vor ansteckung schützen und
welche behandlung gibt es im fall einer
erkrankung julia viegener mit
einzelheiten
neuartig ansteckend im schlimmsten fall
tödlich
das corona virus ein impfstoff ist noch
nicht auf dem markt immer mehr menschen
infizieren sich nun eben zum ersten mal
hier
es gibt keine gefahr in deutschland sich
einfach so aus der umgebung zu
infizieren wir haben hier eine absolut
ausnahmsweise jetzt in einem einzelfall
eingeschleppte erkrankung
was ist kompliziert macht das corona
virus ist ansteckend möglicherweise
schon bevor die ersten symptome
auftreten und das kann bis zu zwei
wochen dauern
natürlich sollte man wenn man
entsprechende symptome entwickelt husten
fieber oder sogar beschimpfen beide
lungenentzündungen sich unbedingt an
einen arzt wenden sagen ich war in china
oder ich hatte kontakt zum beispiel zu
erkranken chinesen und dann wird man
gezielt auf diesen neuen erreger
getestet es wird ausgeschlossen oder
eben bestätigt und dann kommt man ins
krankenhaus und wird entsprechend gut
behandelt und weitere infektionen werden
ihm auch verhindert händewaschen oder in
die armbeuge husten oder niesen wer sich
und andere schützen will sollte sich an
die üblichen hygieneregeln halten um
eine ansteckung zu vermeiden
wir sprechen häufig im öffentlichen
gesundheitswesen so von einer stunde den
mann mit einem infizierten wörtlich
gegenüber sitzen und sich unterhalten
muss wenn wir die vorstellung von
solchen erkrankungen haben die mit so
einer grob tropfen tröpfcheninfektion
übertragen werden
das auswärtige amt jedenfalls warnt vor
reisen in die betroffene provinz hubei
kein risiko eingehen eben und vor allem
keine panik dass deutschland das corona
virus hat deutschland erreicht trotzdem
kein grund zur sorge sagen experten
viele interviews und alles was wir
bisher über die neue lungenkrankheit
wissen können sie online nochmal
nachlesen auf heute.de
es erinnert an einem ritual der
wehrbeauftragte hans peter bartels
stellt seinen jahresbericht vor
inklusive harscher kritik am zustand der
bundeswehr zu wenig material zu wenig
personal zu viel bürokratie für die
enormen kosten die der steuerzahler
trage sagt bartels sei die bundeswehr
bemerkenswert wenig einsatzfähig mathis
feldhoff berichtet der schützenpanzer
puma das neue prunkstück der bundeswehr
doch tatsächlich ist der ein sorgenkind
teuer und nur zu 20 prozent einsatzfähig
für den wehrbeauftragten nur ein
beispiel in einer bundeswehr voller
mängel die bundeswehr als ganzes wäre
heute noch nicht ausgerüstet und
aufgestellt für kollektive verteidigung
eine armee die ihren grundgesetzlichen
auftrag inzwischen kaum noch erfüllen
kann
die ankündigungen der regierung und der
alten ministerinnen haben nicht
gegriffen was noch viel schlimmer ist
die neue ministerin macht genau dort
weiter und keine veränderung in sicht
fast alle soldaten beklagt der
wehrbeauftragte kauften ausrüstungen
zwischen privat weil das schneller und
besser sein
also meinen guten rucksack oder die
stiefel warum dauert das viereinhalb
jahren für 180000 soldaten also drei
paar stiefel auszuliefern
also das sind themen die nach einer
anderen organisation rufen 118 seiten
mängelbericht der fordert weniger
zentralisierung weniger bürokratie etwas
das nicht mal die regierungsseite
ignorieren kann die ausstattung mit
material muss besser werden sie muss
schneller erfolgen dies ist noch nicht
zufriedenstellend
und das hat folgen für die attraktivität
20.000 stellen in der truppe sind
derzeit ungewiss
immerhin die frustration ist
mittlerweile groß und der truppe
insbesondere weil wir jetzt seit fünf
jahren die lücken bei material personal
und infrastruktur beschreiben eine
unendliche geschichte deren lösung wohl
nicht bei immer mehr geld liegt lange
hatte us-präsident trump angekündigt
seinen plan für den nahen osten vor
knapp einer stunde hat er ihn nun
vorgestellt mit dabei israels
ministerpräsident netanyahu die
palästinenser aber nicht trump erklärte
seine vorschläge sehen eine zwei staaten
lösung vor und hier sind die eckpunkte
des plans die palästinenser sollen einen
eigenen souveränen staat in teilen des
westjordanlands erhalten allerdings ohne
die gebiete mit jüdischen siedlungen die
sollen an israel gehen jerusalem soll
für israel die ungeteilte hauptstadt
bleiben ein teil ostjerusalems soll
hauptstadt palästinas werden
britta jäger aus washington für
netanjahu ist trump der beste freund den
israeli im weißen haus hatte also stellt
er sich heute zufrieden neben den us
präsidenten als der seine nahost plan
vorstellt der ist nach netanjahus
geschmack jerusalem wird israels
ungeteilte ungeteilte sehr wichtig
hauptstadt bleiben
meine vision beinhaltet eine win win
lösung für beide seiten eine
realistische zwei staaten lösung die ein
sicherheitsrisiko für israel durch einen
palästinensischen staat verhindert sie
haben verstanden dass israel
souveränität haben muss um sich selbst
verteidigen zu können
trumps plan sieht vor dass der osten
jerusalems zur hauptstadt eines
künftigen palästinenserstaates werden
soll
allerdings unter der kontrolle ist
muslime sollen weiter zugang zur
al-aksa-moschee bekommen
außerdem soll nun der startschuss fallen
für verhandlungen mit den palästinensern
vier jahre zeit sollen sie haben um den
plan anzunehmen meine vision für den
frieden ist fundamental anders als
vergangene pläne
in der vergangenheit hatten selbst die
vorhaben mit bester intention zu wenig
faktische details oder zu theoretische
ideen für trump ist es nun erst einmal
eine vision die aber eine klare
botschaft beinhaltet die usa sind ein
starker partner im nahost konflikt vor
allem für israel
tja da müssen wir natürlich sofort
unsere israel korrespondentin nicola
albrecht in tel aviv fragen wie kommt
trumps plan denn bei den palästinensern
an
nun der präsident der palästinenser
mahmud abbas berät sich derzeit in
ramallah überlegt wie er reagieren soll
sein statement wird in den nächsten
minuten erwartet die hamas spitze die
den gazastreifen regiert hat bereits ein
statement herausgegeben ganz schnell
nach der rede von trump hat sie den
nahost plan abgelehnt hat ihn als
aggressiv und anti palästinensisch
bezeichnet ja und die menschen die sind
zum teil schon seit heute nachmittag auf
der straße auch in diesen minuten
demonstrieren sie in ramallah und in
nablus gegen diesen sogenannten
friedensplan denn in ihren augen bringt
er keinen frieden und vor allem
misstrauen sie grundsätzlich der
us-administration sie glauben nicht dass
unter trump es wirklich für sie einen
souveränen staat mit ost jerusalem als
hauptstadt geben wird es kommt jetzt
vielleicht ein wenig darauf an wie die
arabischen nachbarn in der region
reagieren und vielleicht auch druck auf
die palästinenser ausüben denn dann
könnte möglicherweise wenigsten das
einst diese initiative bewegen
nämlich den schritt zurück an den
verhandlungstisch immerhin haben die
palästinenser bereits 2017 die
diplomatischen beziehungen zu den usa
vollständig abgebrochen
vielen dank nicola für diese ersten
informationen
die britische regierung hat heute eine
scheidung getroffen die deutschland noch
bevorsteht es geht um den aufbau der 5g
mobilfunknetze und ob sich das
chinesische unternehmen way daran
beteiligen darf ja sagt london aber mit
einschränkungen von kernbereichen des
netzes sollen anbieter ausgeschlossen
werden die als riskant gelten
damit wendet sich großbritannien gegen
us-präsident trump der way spionage
vorwirft
der richtungsstreit in der afg hat immer
größere auswirkungen auf die
bundestagsfraktion jetzt ist die
abgeordnete verena hartmann aus partei
und fraktion ausgetreten
auf facebook vergleicht sie den
rechtsnationalen flügel um herrn höcke
mit der npd
der flügel wolle die afg voll und ganz
übernehmen schreibt sie wer sich gegen
die rechtsextreme strömung wäre werde
gnadenlos aus der partei gedrängt
die fraktionsvorsitzende alois seidl
bezeichnete das als so wörtlich völligen
quatsch
zehn jahre ist es her dass man in
deutschland zu erkennen begann in
welchem ausmaß kinder in schulen heimen
und vereinen opfer sexueller gewalt
wurden jahrzehntelang 2010 wurden
zunächst missbrauchsfälle am
katholischen canisius-kolleg bekannt in
der folge meldeten sich viele weitere
menschen die ähnliches erlebt hatten
auch an weltlichen einrichtungen wie der
odenwaldschule
das genaue ausmaß ist nicht zu beziffern
allein auf katholischer seite hat die
kirche nach offiziellen angaben 3677
missbrauchsfälle ermittelt britta
spiekermann hat geschaut wo wir heute
zehn jahre danach stehen
vor genau zehn jahren brach die mauer
des schweigens im berliner canisius
kolleg die schulleitung machte
missbrauchsfälle öffentlich auch weil
frühere schüler den mut hatten die
wahrheit zu sagen
matthias katsch war einer von ihnen
unermüdlich kämpft er für gerechtigkeit
und entschädigung
ich glaube es ist wichtig dass die
gesellschaft jetzt auch mal deutlich
macht dass ihre geduld am ende er ist
also unsere als betroffene ist schon
lange strapaziert
und den verantwortlichen in den kirchen
sagt leute ihr habt jetzt lang genug
taktiert ihr habt jetzt lange genug
verschleppt jetzt ist der punkt wo ihr
auch endlich mal zu entscheidungen
kommen muss bislang gab es in nur 2 1000
fällen bis zu 5000 euro als anerkennung
des leids aber keine wirklichen
entschädigungen 3677 opfer wohnen
zwischen durch eine studie belegt die
dunkelziffer ist deutlich höher
da der zugang zu den archiven bis heute
eingeschränkt ist die bilanz des
unabhängigen beauftragten für fragen des
sexuellen missbrauchs nach zehn jahren
ist ernüchternd die katholische kirche
befindet sich in bezug auf die
aufarbeitung tatsächlich noch in der
anfangsphase hat das ziel noch lange
nicht erreicht
missbrauch auch ein
gesamtgesellschaftliches problem in
familien sportvereinen schulen die
leiterin des hilfs telefons und dass man
sich anonym wenden kann gibt ein
beispiel eine lehrerin ruft an
sie hat letzte woche den rektor
vertreten auf seinem rechner hat sie
missbrauchs abbildung von kindern
entdeckt sehr viele direktor ist zudem
auch noch im kirchenvorstand des ort ist
niemand dürfe wegschauen es brauche
einen pakt gegen den missbrauch von
politik und gesellschaft mit
milliardenschweren investitionen will
die deutsche bahn erschienen und flotten
netzen organisieren doch es läuft nicht
alles rund
der konzern will 25 intercity züge im
wert von 400 millionen euro des
herstellers bombardier nicht abnehmen
grund seien technische mängel betroffen
ist die aktuelle zweite baureihe des
zuges 17 der neuen apple doppelstöckigen
ic züge sind seit gut einem jahr im
einsatz
ja und nun zu dir norbert und zu den
australian open in melbourne
und da kommt es jetzt schon im
halbfinale zum großen showdown federer
gegen djokovic zum fünfzigsten mal
treffen die beiden weltklasse spieler
aufeinander
djokovic der gewann sein
viertelfinalspiel heute souverän
während sich federer ins halbfinale
zitterte und sieben matchbälle abwehren
musste
da steht er und lässt sich feiern für
ein bravourstück das ihm
in über 20 profijahren nicht gelungen
ist manchmal muss man eben glück haben
lakonischer kommentar auf ein
historisches mensch der us-amerikaner
tennis and grey nummer 100 der
weltrangliste hat den sechsfachen
australian-open-sieger mehr vor am rande
der niederlage im vierten satz rettet
sich federer nach abwehr von drei
matchbällen in den tie break
dort wird er weitere vier sieht chancen
des gegners ab einfach unfassbar
federers match war nach dreieinhalb
stunden dieser fünf satz krimi hätte ein
spektakuläres ende verdient gehabt der
triumphator bescheiden
eigentlich habe ich nicht verdient
daraus klar bin ich glücklich das
turnier trägt jetzt schon seine
handschrift und im halbfinale gegen
djokovic droht der nächste kraftakt ex
ski langläufer johannes dürr ist vom
landgericht innsbruck wegen dopings zu
15 monaten auf bewährung verurteilt
worden
der österreicher hatte mit seinen
aussagen die ermittlungen gegen das
doping netzwerk rund um den erfurter
sportmediziner marquez ausgelöst 17
deutsche meisterschaften mit 138 titel
an zwei wettkampftagen das sind die
final 2020 die nach dem großen premieren
erfolg letztes jahr in berlin nun an
rhein und ruhr stattfinden mit neuen
sportarten
nrw-ministerpräsident armin laschet
sprach bei der vorstellung in düsseldorf
heute von einem baustein für eine
mögliche olympia bewerbung rhein ruhr an
den berliner erfolg im letzten jahr will
die region anknüpfen gemeinsam mit
aachen und braunschweig wo die
leichtathleten das um einige sportarten
erweiterte programm ergänzen
neu hinzu kommen die skateboarder und
die sportkletterer die in tokio auch
erstmals olympisch sind in vielerlei
hinsicht bieten sich die final 2020 also
als olympia generalprobe an zu sehen
also am 6
juni alles bei uns live im zdf und ard
seine sicher etwas wärmer morgen aber
sind viel wind schnee und glatte straßen
zu erwarten heute nacht wird es
gefährlich wann sich das wetter beruhigt
das erklärt gleich katja honnefer claus
kleber erwartet sie um drei viertel 10
zum heute-journal und wir würden uns
freuen wenn sie morgen abend
wieder dabei sind um 7 noch ein paar
entspannte stunden heute für sie uns
[Musik]
meine damen und herren das sturmtief
lolita hat sich schnell ein gedreht und
ist weiter gebraucht inzwischen hat das
dänemark erreicht und jetzt entwickelt
sich hier gerade über dem münsterland
ein kleines neues schneetief und das
zieht heute nacht über hamburg weiter
und wird auch mecklenburg vorpommern und
dem norden brandenburgs schnee bringen
über der nordsee gibt es einige gewitter
und in der mitte und im süden sind immer
wieder schnee regen und schneeschauer
unterwegs da es immer noch stürmisch weg
machen sie sich also auch
schneeverwehungen nicht nur in den
mittelgebirgen weit oben gefasst also
tief winterliche straßenverhältnisse
heute nacht morgen beruhigt sich das
wetter allmählich über norddeutschland
sie noch einige gewitter hinweg
es gibt noch schneeregen und schnee
schauer und die sonne macht sich ära sie
sehen sie vielleicht mal rund um die
mittelgebirge es wird immer noch ein
starkes unter stürmischer wind aus
südwestlichen bis westlichen richtungen
heute nacht sinken die temperaturen auf
vier grad an der nordsee und bis minus
zwei grad im vogtland und morgen liegen
die temperaturen zwischen null grad im
thüringer wald und 7 grad auf den
ostfriesischen inseln oder auch am
oberrhein am donnerstag beruhigt sich
das wetter danach wird es deutlich
milder mit bis zu 16 grad und recht
regnerisch schönen abend noch